[Música]
olá meu nome é de ldl santo santo sem o
s no final mesmo e há 13 anos eu ensino
artes visuais para alunos com
deficiência visual
já tô vendo a cara de vocês artes para
cegos isso mesmo eu sou professora e a
minha história na verdade é não começou
lá eu nunca pensei que eu iria trabalhar
com que o trabalho hoje e você também
deve tá achando que eu vim aqui falar
pra vocês sobre inclusão mas eu decidi
falar que hoje sobre transformação sobre
transformar porque eu acredito que para
incluir é isso que a gente precisa fazer
a gente precisa se transformar a gente
precisa transformar o que está à nossa
volta e mais do que isso eu aprendi que
eu precisava transformar a mente dos
meus alunos com deficiência porque eles
passam a vida inteira ouvindo não
ouvindo que não são capazes ouvindo que
não podem então se transformar vai vai
muito além na verdade aquilo que a gente
imagina
eu sempre quis ser professora
então essa menininha ele que aparece no
vídeo com cinco anos ali na pré escola e
ela já brincava de ser professor em casa
mas eu não fazia ideia onde eu iria me
enfiar quando chegasse lá na faculdade
foram 13 anos também estudam numa escola
pública e as minhas chances de ingressar
numa universidade pública elas eram
pequenas
mas eu cheguei lá e com 17 anos para 18
em ingressar na universidade federal do
paraná
mesmo não sabendo muito bem ainda qual
curso que eu queria eu decidi que queria
ser professora de arte
ainda quando estava na faculdade
ah eu tive a oportunidade na verdade de
entrar em contato com esse universo o
que me fez querer trabalhar com pessoas
com deficiência
o incômodo eu fiquei incomodada porque
os meus colegas foram fazer um estágio
numa escola pública e se depararam com
não só um mas três alunos é
dentro da sala de aula e na hora a
primeira coisa que eu pensei como é que
nunca me falaram sobre isso como que
nunca ninguém me disse que alunos com
deficiência estudavam em uma escola em
uma sala comum com que eu ia fazer isso
se eu tivesse lá no lugar deles
ele porque a universidade não falava
sobre essas pessoas porque ela não
preparava de fato a gente enquanto o
professor para trabalhar com esses
alunos e eu tinha então meu primeiro
problema de pesquisa nem sabendo que era
pesquisar mas eu sabia que aquilo tinha
incomodado e eu tinha que fazer alguma
coisa eu queria fazer alguma coisa
também por mim enquanto pessoa enquanto
professora e na primeira oportunidade
que eu tive eu fiz um trabalho uma
exposição na verdade eu nunca quis ser
artista
então eu enganei me a professora fez uma
exposição didática aonde eu ensinava o
que era o desenho através da linha
só que da linha tátil e quando eu
terminei esse material uma colega minha
sala olhou pra mim hoje em dia e por que
você não leva esse material naquela
instituição que fica aqui pertinho da
universidade e já vem meu primeiro ponto
de interrogação uma instituição aqui
perto
eu nunca tinha visto aquele lugar e
curiosamente também nunca tinha visto
uma pessoa cega caminhando ali na rua
próxima a mim provavelmente por várias e
várias vezes enquanto fazia o trajeto do
ônibus até a universidade
eu devo ter atravessado a rua ao lado de
uma pessoa com deficiência e eu nunca
tinha o visto será mesmo que eu nunca
tinha visto eles o eles eram invisíveis
né pra mim então com essa com esse monte
de dúvidas perguntas eu decidi ir até o
instituto essa instituição e levar esse
material que tinha produzido para
aqueles alunos ea única coisa que eu
tinha além de dúvidas era medo não é
deles né eu tinha medo de sentir pena
tinha medo de sentir pena daquelas
crianças que é normalmente o que nós
sentimos quando a gente pensa em alguém
com alguma limitação ou alguma
deficiência
mas aí eu fui recebida por esse abraço
juliana na época com seis anos
e ela desmontou tudo o que eu podia
imaginar sobre o que era ter uma
deficiência
ela tinha olhos brilhantes que não
paravam quietos ela sorria ela era feliz
e ela me fez pensar muito sobre como eu
pensava e o que eu pensava sobre eles
ela me abraçou sem saber o que era
aquilo que eu sentia e eu chamo esse
abraço da juliana de meu presente de
aniversário porque esse dia era o meu
aniversário e eu nunca mais me esqueci
de te abraço assim como também nunca
mais sair desse lugar
nos 13 anos seguintes eu decidi que eu
queria fazer o meu tcc sobre o trabalho
de conclusão de curso sobre a questão do
ensino da arte para alunos com
deficiência visual
eu não sabia nada mas eu queria
descobrir eu queria saber como eles
aprendiam e eu queria saber de que
maneira aquilo que aconteceu com os meus
colegas porque se não acontecer mais
então se fosse comigo que eu iria fazer
a princípio essa minha pesquisa ela
seria uma pesquisa de coleta de dados eu
queria observar
só que quando eu fui buscar instituição
novamente pra saber se eu podia ir lá
fazer pesquisa
a pessoa que me recebeu e me avisou que
eles não tinham as aulas de arte que a
professora tinha ido embora e eu achei
que eu ia ter que desistir da minha
pesquisa mas ela me fez um convite eu
estava no terceiro ano de faculdade
dl por acaso não quer dar aula aqui meu
deus dá aula
como assim dá aula já está louca você
não deu aula nunca nem para crianças que
enxergam que você vai fazer nesse lugar
dando aula para crianças cegas
eu só queria pesquisar só que eu queria
muito fazer aquela pesquisa e eu decidi
aceitar
então a partir daí eu não ia fazer
perguntas
eu precisava encontrar respostas de
verdade para essas perguntas porque
aqueles alunos achavam de verdade que eu
tinha algo para ensinar a eles e além do
medo que eu sentia agora não mais
decente pena porque eu sentia admiração
e eu sentia muita curiosidade é eu
comecei na verdade entender que eu
precisava aprender com eles
eu precisava reaprender e eu precisava
também me reinventar e precisava
reinventar a maneira como as pessoas
ensinado a ensinar a arte nessa
reinvenção eu encontrei mecanismos muito
simples na verdade que pudessem ser
replicadas para que esses alunos
pudessem desenhar compreendeu que
desenhar mostrar para seus colegas de
uma maneira muito simples e que isso
também pudesse ser levado para a escola
onde eles estavam no ensino regular
eu estava ali dentro da educação
especializada nos preparando em são brás
se preparando para ser uma professora
especialista em trabalhar com esses
alunos
mas eu precisava fazer mais além que
estava na minha sala de aula
um dia eles iriam embora dali e eles
iriam para essa outra escola
então como é que eu ia fazer como eu ia
transformar esse trabalho em algo de
fato que tivesse potência de mudar a
vida desses alunos
com o tempo esses alunos que estavam ali
desenhando eles aprenderam de fato a
desenhar eles se apropriaram das
questões relacionadas à arte eles
começaram a gostar de arte e eles não
queriam mais ficar só dentro da sala de
aula e eu também percebi que na verdade
ensinando arte pra ele estava fazendo
muito mais
eu estava mostrando pra eles como era o
mundo de certa forma ea gente acabou
indo para o jardim da escola para o
parque
o campo de futebol para a praia com 30
alunos com deficiência visual
a gente passou a se conhecer mais e eles
ficaram muito curiosos na verdade eles
queriam saber tudo e eles queriam
conhecer o mundo e eu queria mostrar o
mundo inteiro pra eles também ea gente
também foi promoveu que era um espaço
onde as pessoas só diziam não para eles
a primeira coisa que se diz quando você
entra no museu é um toque e um toque não
pode não não e não foi no museu aonde
eles ouviram os maiores não os das vidas
deles e da minha que eu decidi então que
eu iria trabalhar o meu tema da minha
posse do meu trabalho de pós graduação
aí eu já estava há um ano trabalhando
com esses alunos
eu precisava ser especialista para
continuar trabalhando nessa escola e eu
decidi que eu então conversar um pouco
dialogar com essa academia e falar que a
ar que eu também além da sala de aula e
que esses espaços precisavam se adequar
para eles porque o museu era um direito
não é um favor eles estarem lá
eu precisava que eles entendessem também
que esse é um direito deles pra que eles
brigassem pelos seus direitos
é quando terminei o meu trabalho de pós
graduação eu ainda era muito jovem as
pessoas ainda me julgava uma menina
muito sonhadora não é muito doida
pensando naquelas coisas né eu sempre
imaginei algo muito maior do que aquela
sala de aula que a gente estava mas
ainda assim é difícil acreditar no que
eu falava e os meus alunos já estavam lá
criando as suas histórias e eu estava
percebendo também as particularidades
que eles tinham entre eles
eles também eram diferentes dois anos
depois eu achei melhor ir lá então e
fazer um mestrado né porque muita gente
já tava indo na minha sala de aula
conhecer o que eu estava fazendo com
eles eu falei dele se você não fizer
alguém vai fazer e eu fui então para
santa catarina na universidade estadual
santa catarina para tentar colocar no
papel então e comprovada alguma maneira
que a arte de fato estava mudando a vida
daqueles alunos e que ele estava
passando a usar o desenho para se
comunicar muito além de se apropriar da
arte ele estava usando então essas
imagens para mostrar que quem eles eram
pra mostrar como eles viam mundo como
essas imagens se formavam na mente deles
e mesmo assim quando eu terminei meu
mestrado eu ainda não estava satisfeito
porque a academia militar vai dizer o
que as pessoas queriam que eu dissesse
não era a voz deles ainda era minha voz
esses alunos estavam crescendo eles
estavam crescendo e eles estavam
começando também a sair na minha sala de
aula estava começando a se ocupar esses
espaços
ele estava começando a entender a
importância deles nesse processo e um
dia quando eu ainda estava lá sozinha na
minha sala de aula que tinha com os meus
sonhos dos meus planos
uma pessoa de uma consultoria foi até
essa instituição enxergou uma potência
no meu trabalho que nem eu via nela foi
gênio que você faz aqui é transformador
e eu acho que você deveria escrever o
seu trabalho no edital do criança
esperança que trabalha aqui e fui
criança esperança que sonho né eu e meus
alunos já pensou
a gente vê isso lá na tv e assim eu
poderia dizer que essa foi uma das
maiores conquistas da minha história com
os alunos porque nós não vamos aprovar
só uma vez nós fomos aprovados duas
vezes no ano de 2012 no ano de 2015
e nesse intervalo de tempo ainda tivemos
outros apoios financeiros que fizeram
com que não só a instituição mas a
sociedade como um todo enxergasse aquilo
que eu estava fazendo com os alunos na
sala de aula e mais do que isso
começasse a enxergamos eles passaram a
não ser mais invisíveis para as pessoas
então eles começaram a dar entrevista
eles passaram na tv eles começaram a ter
voz de alguma maneira eles começaram a
gostar disso
eles começaram a perceber como eles
também tinham esse poder transformador
que as pessoas ainda diziam que era meu
mas na verdade era todo deles
nesses cinco anos que a gente teve apoio
financeiro a gente pois conseguiu na
verdade é sair desse lugar de público só
e público espectador de arte nos anos
chegaram a mediar uma exposição no maior
museu da cidade
fomos parceiros do museu do holocausto
capacitando aqueles mediadores
a gente já não estava mais no museu só
para apreciar a arte a gente está vendo
lá também para ensinar as pessoas a
gente chegou e até nos no cemitério
municipal para ver o que tinha de arte
lá dentro a gente estava nos lugares
mais inimagináveis fazendo coisas que as
pessoas achavam que eles nunca vão poder
fazer e na verdade em outras cidades
isso já está acontecendo
o museu por exemplo já era um lugar pra
todos em são paulo ea gente foi até lá
foi lá conhecer então um dos museus é
que tem um trabalho fantástico onde as
pessoas com deficiência são mediadoras
já são oficineiros nós somos no museu de
arte moderna de são paulo enchemos um
ônibus com 30 crianças muito pequenas
até jovens e adolescentes
junto com os meus voluntários nós
podemos conhecer de fato um trabalho
acessível ea visibilidade net tivemos
muita visibilidade aparecemos na tv
ganhei prêmio vamos parar no fantástico
eu cheguei a carregar a tocha olímpica
mas eu não estava feliz porque aquelas
conquistas a 0
minhas eu precisava disso precisava que
eles conquistassem de fato as coisas eu
tinha lá comigo então jovens
adolescentes que tinham acesso à arte
tinha acesso à cultura que já estava
ensinando as outras pessoas como elas
deveriam fazer aquilo mas ainda assim
eles não acreditavam que eles eram
capazes de e além daqueles sonhos que as
pessoas sonhavam para eles eu precisava
ensinar-lhes a sonhar sonhar alto pensar
que eles podiam chegar longe que eles
pudessem conquistar aqueles espaços que
de certa forma era eu que estava
ganhando então eu decidi que eu não ia
mais escrever o projeto ver com as mãos
e nenhum edital de financiamento
a minha única meta dali pra frente seria
fazer com que esses alunos acreditassem
neles mesmos
vocês lembram da juliana do meu presente
de aniversário de dez anos depois a
juliana já era uma jovem com poucas
perspectivas que tinha acesso à arte mas
que não sonhava e com aquele abraço que
ela me deu ela me fez acreditar que eu
podia eu tinha praticamente a idade dela
e agora é a minha vez
era a minha vez de abraçar juliana e
mostrar para ela que ela também era
capaz
o que eu fiz então com esses alunos eu
tirei eles desse papel de receber e só
receber e coloquei eles então um papel
de ensinar e formar e capacitar e
habilitar juliana fazendo uma oficina de
capacitação de mediadores com outros
jovens que trabalhavam nos museus
eles começaram a se tornar protagonistas
da mudança que nós queríamos que
acontecesse e eu joguei essa
responsabilidade para eles estão bem pra
que eles entendessem que a potência
daquilo que eles falavam a potência
daquilo que eles acreditavam mudava
muito mais o olhar das pessoas ouvir uma
pessoa com deficiência falar que ela
pode e ela consegue é muito mais forte
do que me ouvirdes é isso que quando a
gente já tava então há quase 12 anos
trabalhando juntos agora sim juntos
nesse projeto
eu tomei uma decisão com o apoio deles
de sair dessa instituição onde eu
trabalhava há 13 anos
a gente decidiu sair junto digamos assim
da escola desses diferentes para tentar
construir essa escola da diferença que a
gente acreditava ser possível e hoje em
dia trabalhando num centro de artes do
estado onde eu atendo também outros
jovens que não têm deficiência eu vejo
esses meus alunos que um dia estavam lá
sem acreditar
fazendo essa mudança acontecer com
outros jovens com outras crianças com
outros professores
hoje em dia o trabalho com formação de
professores e são esses jovens que vão
lá contar pra eles que eles também podem
fazer essa mudança acontecer dentro da
sala de aula como eu fiz na minha
mesmo sem saber nada mesmo sem ter a
formação
essas imagens que eu trago aqui pra
vocês são na verdade aquilo que eu
sempre acreditei
a menina sonhadora lá não dela que
ninguém acreditava que achava que ela
era louca tac olhos dos alunos junto com
outros jovens tendo oportunidades e no
museu e o sorriso daquela jovem
professora que está se formando ainda
para ensinar
olhando pra mim a aluna gabrielli com o
olhar de admiração é nisso que eu
acredito eu apresento então pra vocês a
minha maior conquista os dez jovens
multiplicadores do ver com as mãos que
hoje estão também inserido na
universidade pública estudantes de
jornalismo letras pedagogia educação
física futuros quem sabe professores que
vão transformar também as suas salas de
aula o que me faz hoje acreditar que
ainda tem muita coisa pra mudar e
acontecer é ver o meu filho benício de 2
anos caminhando de mãos dadas com o
bruno e vendo essa mudança de verdade
acontecer
ele também acredita que isso é possível
e quem sabe vocês não saiam daqui hoje
também acreditando que isso possa
acontecer
[Aplausos]